[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory more
specifically welcome to the one
dumentary the most comprehensive guide
on the meanings behind wand history
woods cores lengths and more why ones
you ask well they're one of the
foundations of harry potter let's start
with a history lesson considered to be a
complex and mysterious branch of magic
wand making refers to a want maker using
wand cores and woods to construct ones
for witches and wizards the profession
dates back many many centuries and the
earliest known wand makers were said to
have been druids a druid was considered
to be in celtic times a member of the
learned and priestly class
druids considered anything with a woody
stem to be a tree which led to them
producing ones out of things like vine a
tradition followed by want maker garrick
ollivander in the 20th century though
druids were skilled at their craft at
this stage in history it was still
totally normal for a customer of a one
shop to bring their own core with them a
tradition that has basically fallen off
in more recent times the first want
making shops were known to date back to
the establishment of ollivander's one
shop in 382 bc
the original ollivander the ancestor of
garrick ollivander was thought to have
come from a mediterranean country in
roman times and set up a stall in what
would eventually become diagonally the
etymology of the name ollivander is said
to literally mean he who owns the olive
wand which is a very fitting name and
further points to him coming from a
mediterranean country where olive trees
would grow natively the olivander family
revolutionized wand making when they
publicly forsook the traditional wand
making process which previously had
witches and wizards procure their own
wand core ollivander believed that this
process produced ones that were inferior
in quality and performance which led to
the family procuring all one components
for future customers
olivander researched the best one cause
and would always find the best wand
would to complement it and where the
purchaser would previously select a wand
of their choosing he began the tradition
of having the wand choose the wizard now
if you're any sort of harry potter fan
at all then you'll know that ones are
tools that witches and wizards use to
channel their magic we're introduced to
ollivander's one shop right near the
beginning of the philosopher's stone
when harry is picking up his supplies
for hogwarts harry is ultimately given
an 11 inch wand made of holly with the
phoenix feather core and what's
interesting about ones is that they
choose the wizard rather than the other
way around wizards and ones share an
almost symbiotic relationship and that's
why someone's simply won't work for
certain people a wand is the object
through which a witch or wizard channels
his or her magic it is made from wood
and has a magical substance at its core
ones made by olivander have cause of
phoenix feather unicorn hair or dragon
heart string and are of varying woods
lengths and flexibilities as shown above
ones come in a variety of shapes colors
sizes flexibilities and materials the
main parameters that differentiate each
wand are as follows length flexibility
wood type and lastly core type each
element is just as important as the last
but before we get into the meanings
behind the woods and cause let me first
briefly explain two other overlooked
wand characteristics their lengths and
flexibilities length generally pertains
to the size and or character of the
witch wizard
most ones are between 9 to 15 inches
long wand makers often match the one
length to the height of the witch or
wizard who will use it but ollivander
considers this measure inadequate in his
experience
longer than average ones tend to be
drawn to those with a physical
peculiarity or a bigger personality
whereas abnormally short ones select
people whose character lacks in
something notably characters like
gildora lockhart criminalisquirrel and
piece of pettigrew and quite small ones
reflective of their weakness and
character on the flip side of this
characters like hagrid neville and even
ollivander himself had quite large ones
reflective of either their physical
stature and or strength of character
okay now what about flexibility what
does that have to do with anything
according to pottermore one flexibility
is important but should not be looked at
as a standalone component but rather a
piece of a whole package one flexibility
or rigidity denotes the degree of
adaptability and willingness to change
possessed by the ones and owner pair
although again this factor ought not to
be considered separately from the one
wood core and length nor of the owner's
life experience and style of magic all
of which will combine to make the wand
in question unique all right so now that
we've got length and flexibility out of
the way let's move on to the big stuff
wonder woods and cores starting with
woods
the wood used in a wand is the component
with the highest variability as there
are 38 different types available the
number of different wood materials used
to make ones make them very personal and
is one of the reasons that one wand can
look so unlike the next ollivander
discusses which trees can produce wood
for ones here only a minority of trees
can produce one quality wood just as a
minority of humans can produce magic it
takes years of experience to tell which
ones have the gift although the job is
made easier if boat charcoals are found
nesting in the leaves as they never
inhabit mundane trees today i'm going to
be starting off our wand journey by
discussing every one word in existence
that is every wood material that could
potentially be used to make a wand a lot
of information pertaining to ones is
best described by ollivander himself so
i'm going to be using his own
explanations after the words i'll
explain the cause and then i've got some
bonus content for you when all of that
is over let's get into the woods
starting in alphabetical order acacia
acacia is a large genus of shrubs and
trees that belongs to the subfamily memo
saudia of the family ferbacii first
described in africa apparently this type
of one word is particularly hard to
match with a witch or wizard ollivander
had this to say
a very unusual wand wood which i've
found creates tricky ones that often
refuse to produce magic for any but
their owner and also withhold their best
effects from all but those most gifted
this sensitivity renders them difficult
to place and i keep only a small stock
for those witches or wizards of
sufficient subtlety for acacia is not
suited to what is commonly known as bang
and smells magic the only known wizard
to have potentially had this material in
his wand is jacob's sibling from the
hogwarts mystery game
alder ulda is the common name of a
genius of flowering plants allness
belonging to the birch family bettu
lacie the genus ulness comprises about
30 species of different trees and shrubs
that are commonly found near streams
rivers and wetlands ollivander had this
to say
alder is an unyielding wood yet i have
discovered that its ideal owner is not
stubborn or obstinate but often helpful
considerate and to most likeable whereas
most one words seek similarity in the
characters of those that they will best
serve older is unusual in that it seems
to desire a nature that is if not
precisely opposite to its own than
certainly of a markedly different type
he also added that it is best suited to
non-verbal spell work
kurana squirrel notably used an older
wand that was nine inches in length
apple i'm sure you've heard of apple
trees before which come from the species
malus domestica in the rose family
olivendar had this to say
applewood ones are not made in great
numbers they are powerful and best
suited to an owner of high aims and
ideals as this wood mixes poorly with
dark magic it is said that the possessor
of an apple wand will be well loved and
long lived but i've often noticed that
customers of great personal charm find
their perfect match in an applewood wand
one other interesting aspect of
applewood one donors is that they can
commonly converse with other magical
beings in their native tongues
on that note a wizard by the name of
dylan marwood who authored merpeople a
comprehensive guide to their language
and customs was known to have used an
apple wood wand
ash the ash tree is a type of tree
belonging to the genus fraxinus
containing flowering plants in the olive
and lilac family ollivander had this to
say
the ash wand cleaves to its one true
master and ought not to be passed on or
gifted from the original owner because
it will lose power and skill
this tendency is extreme if the core is
of unicorn old superstitions regarding
ones rarely bear close examination
but i find that the old rhyme regarding
rowan chestnut ash and hazel ones
rowan gossips chestnut drones ash's
stubborn hazel moans contains a small
nugget of truth he also added that the
ideal owner may be stubborn and will
certainly be courageous but never crass
or arrogant on the vein of or not to be
passed on or gifted this is actually the
wand that was passed down from charlie
weasley to ron weasley hence why ron had
so many difficulties with his first wand
aspen aspen is a common name for certain
tree species some of which are
classified by the genus populous these
types of trees are endemic to the
northern hemisphere ollivander had this
to say
one quality aspenwood is white and fine
grained and is highly prized by all want
makers for its stylish resemblance to
ivory and it's usually outstanding charm
work the proper owner of the aspen wand
is often an accomplished duelist or
destined to be so for the aspen wand is
one of those particularly suited to
martial magic
bearing that in mind there are no known
owners of an aspen wand according to
canon
other than members of an infamous and
secretive 18th century dueling club
called the silver spears which would
only admit those who used an aspen wand
beech
beech is the common name for a genus of
ten species of deciduous trees in the
family for jca these types of trees are
endemic to great britain ollivander had
this to say
the true match for a beach wand will be
if young lies beyond his or her years
and if full-grown rich in understanding
and experience
beach ones perform very weakly for the
narrow-minded and intolerant
such wizards and witches having obtained
a beach wand without having been
suitably matched yet coveting this most
desirable richly hued and highly prized
wand wood have often presented
themselves at the homes of learned want
makers such as myself
demanding to know the reason for the
handsome one's lack of power when
properly matched the beach wand is
capable of a subtlety and artistry
rarely seen in any other wand hence its
lustrous reputation i wasn't able to
find any information on witches or
wizards that use a beach wand
blackthorne blackthorne aka prunus
spinosa is a species of flowering plant
in the rose family rosaceae
it is native to europe western asia and
locally in north west africa
ollivander had this to say
blackthorne which is a very unusual one
would has the reputation in my view
well-merited of best being suited to the
warrior this does not necessarily mean
that its owner practices the dark arts
although it is undeniable that those who
do so will enjoy the blackthorne ones
prodigious power
one finds blackthorne ones among the
auras as well as among the denizens of
azkaban as far as witches wizards that
use blackthorne ones only two are known
the first is circadogen a wizard and
swore knight of the round table and the
second was an unnamed snatcher
black walnut black walnut is a specific
type of walnut that is native to eastern
north america growing mainly in wetlands
ollivander had this to say less common
than the standard walnut wand that of
black walnut seeks a master of good
instincts and powerful insight black
walnut is a very handsome wood but not
the easiest to master it has one
pronounced quirk which is that it is
abnormally attuned to inner conflict and
loses power dramatically if its
possessor practices any form of
self-deception this want word is said to
be particularly useful when it comes to
charm work there are no known witches or
wizards in canon that use this wand wood
cedar
cedar aka sidris is a genus of
coniferous trees in the plant family
penicie
they are native to the mountains of the
western himalayas and the mediterranean
region ollivander had this to say
whenever a meat one who carries a cedar
wand i find strength of character and
unusual loyalty my father gervais
ollivander
used to always say you will never fool
the cedar carrier and i agree the cedar
wand finds its perfect home where there
is perspicacity and perception
one known cedar one donor is none other
than professor horace slughorn
cherry now i'm sure you've heard of
cherry trees before trees that come from
the genus prunus i'm sure you've also
heard of some of the witches and wizards
that use cherry ones but first let's
hear what ollivander has to say this
very rare wanderwood creates a wand of
strange power most highly prized by the
wizarding students of the school
mahutukuro in japan where those who own
cherry ones have special prestige the
western wand purchaser should dispel
from their minds any notion that the
pink blossom of the living tree makes
for a frivolous or merely ornamental
wand for cherry wood often makes a wand
that possesses truly lethal power
known cherry wand owners include neville
longbottom gilderoy lockhart and albus
potter
chestnut chestnuts are a group of eight
or nine species of deciduous trees and
shrubs in the genus castaner in the
beech family for jca
they are native to temperate regions of
the northern hemisphere the name
chestnut also refers to the edible nuts
produced by these trees ollivander had
this to say
this is a most curious multi-faceted
wood which varies greatly in its
character depending on the wand core and
takes a great deal of color from the
personality that possesses it the wand
of chestnut is attracted to witches and
wizards who are skilled tamers of
magical beasts those who possess great
gifts in herbology and those who are
natural flyers known chestnut one donors
include peter pettigrew
cyprus cyprus is the name applied to
many of the plants belonging to the
cypress family most cypress species are
trees while a few are shrubs
ollivander had this to say
cypress ones are associated with
nobility the great medieval wand maker
geraint ollivander
wrote that he was always honoured to
match a cyprus wand for he knew he was
meeting a witch or wizard who would die
a heroic death
fortunately in these last bloodthirsty
times the possessors of cyprus ones are
rarely called upon to lay down their
lives though doubtless many of them
would do so if required
known cyprus one donors include remus
lupin which fits perfectly
dogwood dogwood comes from cornice a
genus of about thirty to sixty species
of woody plants in the family cornicie
which can generally be distinguished by
their blossoms berries in distinctive
bark olivander had this to say
dogwood is one of my own personal
favorites and i found that matching a
dogwood wand with its ideal owner is
always entertaining
dogwood ones are quirky and mischievous
they have playful natures and insist
upon partners who can provide them with
scope for excitement and fun it would be
quite wrong however to deduce from this
the dogwood ones are not capable of
serious magic when called upon to do so
one peculiar aspect of dogwood ones
however is that they refuse to perform
non-verbal magic there are no known
witches wizards in canon that use a
dogwood wand ebony ebony is a dense
black brown hardwood most commonly
yielded by several species in the genus
diosperos it is finely textured and has
a mirror finish when polished making it
valuable as an ornamental wood olivander
had this to say
this jet black wantwood has an
impressive appearance and reputation
being highly suited to all manners of
combative magic and to transfiguration
ebony is happiest in the hand of those
with the courage to be themselves
frequently non-conformist highly
individual or comfortable with the
status of outsider ebony wand owners
have been found both among the ranks of
the order of the phoenix and among the
death eaters there are no known witches
wizards in canon that use an ebony wand
elder you have got to know this one
elderwood which is the rarest word of
all comes from the genus sambucus a
genus of between 5 and thirty species of
shrubs or small trees in the moschitel
family ollivander had this to say
the rarest wanderwood of all and reputed
to be deeply unlucky the elder wand is
trickier to master than any other it
contains powerful magic but scorns to
remain with any owner who is not the
superior of his or her company
it takes a remarkable wizard to keep the
elder wand for any length of time
the old superstition wand of elder never
prosper has its basis in this fear of
the wand but in fact the superstition is
baseless and those foolish want makers
who refuse to work with elder
do so more because they doubt that they
will be able to sell their products than
from fear of working with this wood
known owners of ones well one wand
containing elder wood include antioch
peverell emmerich the evil eggbert the
egregious godolo herwood barnabas cuff
loxius gregorovich grindelwald
dumbledore malfoy and harry potter elm
elms are deciduous and semi-deciduous
trees comprising the flowering plant
genus ulmus in the plant family el
messier these trees are spread over most
of the northern hemisphere ollivander
had this to say
the truth is that elm ones prefer owners
with presence magical dexterity and a
certain native dignity of all wonder
words elm in my experience produces the
fewest accidents the least foolish
errors and the most elegant charms and
spells these are sophisticated ones
capable of highly advanced magic in the
right hands lucius malfoy inherited his
own elm wand from his father abraxas
malfoy
english oak english oak is a species of
flowering plant in the beach and oak
family for jca it is native to most of
western europe ollivander had this to
say
a wand for good times and bad this is a
friend as loyal as the wizard who
deserves it ones of english oak demand
partners of strength courage and
fidelity
less well-known is the propensity for
owners of english oak ones to have
powerful intuition and often an affinity
with the magic of the natural world but
the creatures and plants that are
necessary to wizard kind for both magic
and pleasure
known owners of oak ones include rubius
hagrid and potentially the most powerful
wizard to have ever lived merlin
fur
furs are a genus of 48 to 56 species of
evergreen coniferous trees in the family
penicie they are found through much of
north and central america europe asia
and north africa
occurring in mountains over most of the
range ollivander had this to say of
furwood
my great-grandfather gobbled octavius
ollivander always called ones of this
wood the survivor's wand because he had
sold it to three wizards who
subsequently passed through mortal peril
unscathed there is no doubt that this
wood coming as it does from the most
resilient of trees produces ones that
demand staying power and strength of
purpose in their true owners and that
they are poor tools in the hands of the
changeable and indecisive fur ones are
particularly suited to transfiguration
minerva mcgonagall notably used a wand
made of fur makes sense
hawthorne hawthorne is a species of
flowering plant in the rose family
rosaceae it is native to europe
northwestern africa and west asia but
has also been introduced in many other
parts of the world interestingly
ollivander and want maker gregorovich
who often disagree are on the same page
about this one grugorovich had this to
say
hawthorne makes a strange contradictory
wand as full of paradoxes as the tree
that gave it birth whose leaves and
blossoms heal and yet whose cut branches
smell of death olivander continues while
i disagree with many of gragorovich's
conclusions we concur about hawthorne
ones which are complex and intriguing in
their natures just like the owners who
best suit them hawthorne ones may be
particularly suited to healing magic but
they are also adept at curses
and i have generally observed that the
hawthorne wand seems most at home with a
conflicted nature or with a witch or
wizard passing through a period of
turmoil draco malfoy notably used a wand
made of hawthorne
hazel hazel is a genius of deciduous
trees and large shrubs native to the
temperate northern hemisphere olivander
had this to say
a sensitive wand hazel often reflects
its owner's emotional state and works
best for a master who understands and
can manage their own feelings
others should be very careful handling a
hazel wand if its owner has recently
lost their temper or suffered a serious
disappointment because the wand will
absorb such energy and discharge it
unpredictably
trelloni notably used wand made of hazel
holly holly comes from the genus alexis
which is comprised of about 480 species
of flowering plants in the family
aquifoliaceae
the species are evergreen or deciduous
trees shrubs and climbers from tropics
to temperate zones worldwide ollivander
had this to say
holly is one of the rarer kinds of want
woods traditionally considered
protective it works most happily for
those who may need help overcoming a
tendency to anger and impetuosity at the
same time holy ones often choose owners
who are engaged in some dangerous and
often spiritual quest harry potter the
boy who lived notably used a wand made
of holly
hornbeam hornbeams are hardwood trees in
the flowering plant genus carpenus in
the birch family the 30 to 40 species
can be found across much of the
temperate regions of the northern
hemisphere ollivander who has a hornbeam
wand himself had this to say my own wand
is made of hornbeam and so it is with
all due modesty that i state that
hornbeam selects for its lifemate the
talented witch or wizard with a single
pure passion which some might call
obsession though i prefer the term
vision which will almost always be
realized hornbeam ones adapt more
quickly than almost any other to their
owner's style of magic and will become
so personalized so quickly that other
people will find them extremely
difficult to use even for the most
simple of spells two known owners of
hornbeam ones include ollivander as
mentioned above and victor crum
larch larches are deciduous conifers
from the genus laryx these plants can
grow anywhere from 20 to 45 meters tall
and are native to much of the cooler
temperate northern hemisphere ollivander
had this to say strong durable and warm
in color larch has long been valued as
an attractive and powerful wanderwood
its reputation for instilling courage
and confidence in the user has ensured
the demand has always outstripped supply
this much sought after wand is however
hard to please in the matter of ideal
owners and trickier to handle than many
imagine i find that it always creates
ones of hidden talents and unexpected
effects which likewise describes the
master who deserves it celestina warbeck
a hogwarts graduate and popular singer
notably used a wand made of larch
laurel laurel belongs to the genus loras
which is comprised of evergreen trees
olivand had this to say of laurel wood
it is said that a laurel wand cannot
perform a dishonorable act although in
the quest for glory a not uncommon goal
for those best suited to these ones i
have known that laurel ones perform
powerful and sometimes lethal magic
laurel ones are sometimes called fickle
but this is unfair the laurel wand seems
unable to tolerate laziness in a
possessor and it is in such conditions
that it is most easily and willingly won
away otherwise it will cleave happily to
its first match forever and indeed as
the unusual and engaging attribute of
issuing a spontaneous lightning strike
if another witcher wizard attempts to
steal it that lightning strike is quite
a good defense mechanism we can only
imagine how messy things would have been
if the same thing occurred for the elder
wand it's worth noting that there are no
known witches and wizards in canon that
use a laurel wood wand maple maples fall
into the genus acer a family of trees
and shrubs of which there are
approximately 132 species
most of these species are native to asia
with a number also appearing in europe
northern africa and north america
ollivander had this to say of maple i
have often found that those chosen by
maple ones are by nature travelers and
explorers they are not stay-at-home ones
and prefer ambition in their witch or
wizard otherwise their magic grows heavy
and lackluster
fresh challenges and regular changes of
scene cause this wand to literally shine
burnishing itself as it grows with its
partner inability and status there are
no known canon owners of maple ones
pear
pear trees which come from the genus
pyrus are most well known for producing
a fruit of the same name the tree is
medium-sized and native to coastal and
mildly temperate regions of europe north
africa and asia ollivander had this to
say of pear trees this golden-toned wood
produces ones of splendid magical powers
which give off their best in the hands
of the warm-hearted the generous and the
wise
possessors of pair wands are in my
experience usually popular and well
respected
i do not know of a single instance where
a pair wand has been discovered in the
possession of a dark witch or wizard
there are no known canon owners of pear
ones
pine pine comes from the genus pinus of
the peninsula family there are about 115
species of pine although different
authorities accept between 105 and 125
species ollivander had this to say of
pine
the straight grained pined wand always
chooses an independent individual master
who may be perceived as a loner
intriguing and perhaps mysterious
pint ones enjoy being used creatively
and unlike some others will adapt
unprotestingly to new methods and spells
many want makers insist that pint ones
are able to detect and perform best for
owners who are destined for long lives
there are no known canon owners of pine
ones
poplar
poplar comes from the genus populous a
genus of 25 to 30 species of deciduous
flowering plants in the family salicasia
native to most of the northern
hemisphere ollivander had this to say of
poplar if you seek integrity search
first among the poplars was a great
maxim of my grandfather gerbild
olivander and my own experience of
popular ones and their owners tallies
exactly with this
here is a wand to rely upon of
consistency strength and uniform power
always happiest when working with the
witch or wizard of clear moral vision
two of the ministry of magic's most
accomplished ministers used popular ones
eldritch diggory and evangeline
orpington red oak red oak also known as
northern red oak is an oak inn you
guessed it the red oak group it is a
native of north america in the eastern
and central united states as well as
southeast and south central canada
ollivander had this to say of red oak
ones you will often hear the ignorant
say that red oak is an infallible sign
of its owner's hot temper
in fact the true match for a red oak
wand is possessed of unusually fast
reactions making it a perfect dueling
wand less common than english oak i have
found that its ideal master is light of
touch quick-witted and adaptable often
the creator of distinctive trademark
spells and a good man a woman to have
beside one in a fight there are no known
canon owners of red oak ones
redwood redwoods also known as sequoio
day is a subfamily of coniferous trees
within the family
cupra sassier some of the largest and
tallest trees in the world are redwoods
so i'm sure we can expect great things
here olivenda had this to say
one to quality redwood is in short
supply yet constant demand due to its
reputation for bringing good fortune to
its owner as is usually the case with
one to law the general populace have the
truth back to front redwood ones are not
themselves lucky
but are strongly attracted to witches
and wizards who already possess the
admirable ability to fall on their feet
to make the right choice to snatch
advantage from catastrophe there are no
known canon owners of redwood ones rowan
rowan which comes from the genus sorbus
are comprised of shrubs and small trees
from the rosaceae family they are native
throughout the cool temperate regions of
the northern hemisphere with the highest
species diversity in the mountains of
the himalayas ollivander had this to say
rowanwood has always been much favored
for once because it is reputed to be
more protective than any other and in my
experience renders all manner of
defensive charms especially strong and
difficult to break
it is commonly stated that no dark witch
or wizard ever owned a rowan wand and i
cannot recall a single instance where
one of my own rowan ones has gone on to
do evil in the world ollivander also
once noted that wizards chosen by rowan
ones tend to be compassible with those
chosen by elder ones interesting there
are also no known canon owners of rowan
ones
silver lime the unusual named silva lime
is a species of flowering plant in the
family
malvasier native to southeastern europe
and south western asia ollivander had
this to say
this unusual and highly attractive wand
wood was greatly in vogue in the 19th
century
demand outstripped supply and
unscrupulous want makers dyed
substandard ones in an effort to fool
purchasers into believing that they had
purchased silver lime the reasons for
these ones desirability lay not only in
their unusually handsome appearance but
also because they had a reputation for
performing best for sears and those
skilled in legitimacy there are no known
canon owners of silverline ones spruce a
spruce is a tree of the genus pasilla
which is comprised of about 35 species
of coniferous evergreen trees in the
family pinaceae found in the northern
temperate and boreal regions of the
earth ollivander had this to say of
spruce ones
want makers call spruce a difficult wood
but in doing so they reveal their own
ineptitude it is quite true that it
requires particular deafness to work
with spruce which produces ones that are
ill-matched with cautious or nervous
natures and become positively dangerous
in fumbling fingers the spruce wand
requires a firm hand because it often
appears to have its own ideas about what
magic it ought to be called upon to
produce however when a spruce wand meets
its match which in my experience is a
bold spell caster with a good sense of
humor it becomes a superb helper
intensely loyal to their owners and
capable of producing particularly
flamboyant and dramatic effects there
are no known canon owners of spruce ones
sycamore the sycamore is a name which
has actually been applied to several
types of trees with somewhat similar
leaf forms in harry potter sycamore
trees can be found in the forest of dean
as well as the forbidden forest
ollivander had this to say of sycamores
the sycamore makes a questing wand eager
for new experience and losing brilliance
if engaged in mundane activities it is a
quirk of these handsome ones that they
may combust if allowed to become bored
and many witches and wizards settling
down into middle age are disconcerted to
find their trusty wand bursting into
flame in their hand as they ask it one
more time to fetch their slippers
as may be deduced the sycamores ideal
owner is curious vital and adventurous
there are no known cannon owners of
sycamore ones
vine vines refer to any plant with a
growth habit of trailing or scandant
that is to say climbing stems or runners
however in some parts of the world the
british isles included the term vine is
applied exclusively to grapevines
olivander had this to say of vines
vine ones are among the less common
types and i've been intrigued to notice
that their owners are nearly always
those witches and wizards who seek a
greater purpose who have a vision beyond
the ordinary and who frequently astound
those who think they know them best
vine ones seem strongly attracted by
personalities with hidden depths and i
found them more sensitive than any other
when it comes to instantly detecting a
prospective match hermione granger
notably possessed a ten and
three-quarter inch wand made with vine
walnut walnut trees are a large
deciduous tree species from the genus
jugulans that produce edible walnuts
olivander had this to say of walnuts
highly intelligent witches and wizards
ought to be offered a walnut wand for
trial first because in nine cases out of
ten the two will find in each other
their ideal mate walnut ones are often
found in the hands of magical innovators
and inventors this is a handsome wood
possessed of unusual versatility and
adaptability bellatrix lestrange notably
possessed a twelve and three quarter
inch wand made with walnut willow
willows also called sallows form the
genus salix which is comprised of around
400 species of deciduous trees and
shrubs that can be found primarily on
moist soils in cold and temperate
regions of the northern hemisphere
ollivander had this to say of willows
willow is an uncommon wonder wood with
healing power and i've noted that the
ideal owner for a willow wand often has
some usually unwarranted insecurity
however well they may try and hide it
while many confident customers insist on
trying a willow wand attracted by their
handsome appearance and well-founded
reputation for enabling advanced
non-verbal magic my willow ones have
consistently selected those of greatest
potential rather than those who feel
they have little to learn
ron weasley's second wand was notably
made of willow u and last of all we have
u
u refers to various coniferous trees and
shrubs in the genus taxis in harry
potter yew trees can be found in the
forbidden forest ollivander had this to
say of you you ones are among the rarer
kinds and their ideal matches are
likewise unusual and occasionally
notorious the wonderview is reputed to
endow its possessor with the power of
life and death which might of course be
said of all ones and yet you retains a
particularly dark and fearsome
reputation in the spheres of dueling and
all curses
tom middle's first wand was made of you
as was ginny weasley's all right so
hopefully that explanation on one words
gives you at least a little bit more
information on the trees behind these
magical instruments but wait the fun
doesn't end there as now we're going to
be diving into the other primary and
equally important component of a wand
the wand core
like the wood the wand core will act as
an extension of the wizard themself
allowing them to properly tap into their
most powerful innate magical abilities
if you have the right wand then you will
always be able to channel your magic
better than with a less suited
counterpart the wonder maker of which we
are most familiar ollivander has a
tendency to utilize three primary wand
cores phoenix unicorn and dragon however
what i want to discuss in this video are
some of the other lesser-known cores
first let's hear what ollivander has to
say about the three that he personally
uses early in my career as i watched my
wondermaker father wrestling with
substandard one core materials such as
kelpie hair i conceived the ambition to
discover the finest cause and to work
only with those when my time came to
take over the family business this i
have done after much experimentation and
research
i concluded that only three substances
produce ones of the quality to which i'm
happy to give the illustrious name of
olivander unicorn hair dragon heart
string and phoenix feather each of these
costly and rare materials has its own
distinct properties so as you can see
above though ollivander is fully aware
of the presence of other available
wonderful materials he chooses to stick
with dragon phoenix and unicorn because
they are the most reliable and allow him
to consistently make powerful ones this
makes sense because they are all
powerful creatures however there are
other types of cause and i think that
olivander is being a little unfair here
as i'm positive some of the others have
benefits as well in this video i'm going
to take a look at them all let's start
with the big three
dragon from pottermore as a rule dragon
heart strings produce ones with the most
power and which are capable of the most
flamboyant spells dragon ones tend to
learn more quickly than other types
while they can change allegiance if one
from their original master they always
bond strongly with the current owner the
dragon one tends to be easiest to turn
to the dark arts though it will not
incline that way of its own accord it is
also the most prone of the three cause
to accidents being somewhat
temperamental
phoenix from pottermore phoenix feathers
are capable of the greatest range of
magic though they may take longer than
either unicorn or dragon cause to reveal
this they show the most initiative
sometimes acting of their own accord
equality that many witches and wizards
dislike phoenix feather ones are always
the pickiest when it comes to potential
owners for the creature from which they
are taken is one of the most independent
and detached in the world
unicorn from pottermore unicorn hair
generally produces the most consistent
magic and is least subject to
fluctuations and blockages ones with
unicorn cores are generally the most
difficult to turn to the dark arts they
are the most faithful of all ones and
usually remain strongly attached to
their first owner irrespective of
whether he or she was an accomplished
witch or wizard okay so now that we've
got the big three out of the way let's
dive into the lesser-known stuff vela
vila hair ones come from well vela
semi-human magical beings that resemble
beautiful women with white cold hair and
moon bright skin
flor de la cour notably has a velar hair
core in her wand and olivander had
described vela hair as highly
temperamental which makes sense i
suspect that grogorovich may have used
velaheb in his wands as well
basilisk it has been expressed that the
horn of a basilisk can be used as a wand
core and was notably used by hogwarts
founder salazar slytherin for his own
wand this should come as no surprise
given his affinity for basilisks giant
serpentine beasts often affiliated with
dark wizards
wampus cat wampus cat hair is a core
material used by american wand maker
johannes yonker the wampus cat is a
magical cat native to the united states
and is actually the symbol for one of
the houses at ilvermorny's school
thunderbird thunderbird tail feathers
come from the famously powerful magical
beast the thunderbird a large cousin of
the phoenix that capable of causing
storms the thunderbird is also one of
the house symbols at ilvermorny school
snellygaster the snallygaster
heartstring core comes from the magical
beast the snallygaster this core was
used by izoltser to make ones for some
of those that began attending
ilvermorny's school
jackalope another of the one core types
utilized by izoltser of ilvermorny the
jackalope antler comes from the fabled
jackalope a mythical creature from north
american folklore described as a
jackrabbit with antelope horns
rugaru rugaru hair comes from the
dangerous dog-headed magical beast that
inhabits the us
rugaru are said to resemble werewolves
sporting the head of a dog and the body
of a human
rugaru hair cores are used by american
wand maker violetta bouvey
some believe that rugaru hair has a
connection with the dark arts since
rugaru are highly dangerous magical
beasts seraphina piccare former
president of makusa has a magaru hair in
her wand
thestral testral hair comes from the
fabled magical beast the thestral if you
weren't already aware thestrals are a
breed of winged horse with a skeletal
body face with reptilian features and
wide bat-like wings the argument could
be made that the thestral hair corp is
the most powerful of all one's cause as
the elder wand itself is the only one in
existence known to use it however it is
also possibly the most unstable and most
difficult to use of all the cores
troll troll whisker cores come from the
facial hair of trolls massive albeit
stupid creatures that exist in the
magical world control whisker cores are
considered to be a relatively inadequate
wand material however they are passable
ditny ditny stalk cores are the only
causing canon that come from a plant at
least it's the only one that we know
about
ditny is a powerful restorative healing
herb that may be eaten raw to cure
shallow wounds
horned serpent horned serpent horns are
taken from you guessed it horned
serpents large magical snakes with a
multitude of abilities the core was used
by izoltser and is said to be
exceptionally powerful
additionally the one core itself is
sensitive to parcel tongue and is said
to vibrate when parcel tongue is being
spoken
the core also warns the owner of danger
by emitting a low musical tone
white river monster white river monster
spines come from white river monsters a
magical fish native to the white river
in arkansas the wand core was pretty
much exclusively used by wand maker
thiago quintana and the cores were
thought to produce spells of great
elegance and force bone apparently all
sorts of bones can be used as one cause
there's no canon evidence anywhere to
suggest that any particular type of bone
is better but apparently they can be
used ones containing a bone core may
also simultaneously contain a shell core
shell similar to the peculiar use of
bone above it has been expressed that
shell can also be used as a one core
mute commander notably had a wand with
elements of shell at its core
coral coral exists in our own world a
marine invertebrate however in harry
potter it has magical properties and can
be used as a wand core want to make a
gorovich notably uses coral one cores in
some of his ones
kurupira kurupira
redhead forest dwelling dwarves native
to brazil it is a notoriously unstable
one core but it has been expressed that
if the one chooses you then you must be
a very talented wizard
kelpie last but not least well sort of
least we have the kelpie air corps
kelpie here is of course from kelpies
shape-shifting water demons native to
great britain ollivander himself has
publicly denounced the usage of kelpie
hare in his ones early in my career as i
watched my one to make a father
wrestling with substandard one core
materials such as kelpie hair i
conceived the ambition to discover the
finest cause
and with that final note on one cause i
think i've provided you with about as
much information as i can on the history
and physical characteristics of ones
you're now an expert with 20 different
one cores and a staggering 38 wand woods
that we know about the combinations are
endless which is one of the reasons that
there's so much variety in the wizarding
world
add length and flexibility into the mix
we've nearly got a guarantee that no two
ones will be exactly the same
one last question that i want to tackle
however is whether using a wand is
actually necessary the importance of one
donorship in harry potter is emphasized
to suggest that essentially no witch or
wizard no matter how powerful or weak is
complete without their wand the wand
chooses the wizard that much has always
been clear to those of us who have
studied one's law if you are any wizard
at all you will be able to channel your
magic through almost any instrument the
best results however must always come
where there is the strongest affinity
between wizard and wand these
connections are complex an initial
attraction and then a mutual quest for
experience the one to learning from the
wizard the wizard from the wand and from
the day the pairing of wand in which
wizard first occurs the wand becomes
more and more a vital part of their
existence the one and once owner
establish an almost symbiotic
relationship and part of this aspect
comes down to the fact that ones are
quasi-sentient able to independently
perform actions through their own will
okay so ones are important and the
relationship with their caster is
important but the first thing i want to
look at here before we get to multiple
ones is are they necessary we see some
wonderless magic in harry potter and
it's always a bit confusing wait a
second don't you need a one to perform
that spell well here's the thing
wonderless magic only really stands out
to us because of its ubiquity among the
wizarding world that we have become
familiarized with through the books and
films we are indoctrinated from the
start to think that a wand is essential
to magical achievement where in reality
oneless magic is actually a norm for
other species and cultures perfect
examples of magical beings that are able
to perform magic without ones include
goblins and elves whose lack of wand
usage has even prompted them to refer to
humans as wand-bearers expanding on this
in the world of harry potter the wand is
said to be a european invention which
means that cultures outside of europe
would have always practiced magic
without one it is said that native
american wizards have their own methods
of producing magic predating
colonization and that african wizards
only adopted the wand in the 20th
century so really oneless magic is a lot
more common than you may think and on
that note we've reached the end of this
video what's your wand what did you
learn in this video comment down below
and if you enjoyed the video please be
sure to give it a like and to subscribe
to the channel until next time remember
the one to chooses the wizard mr potter
is not always clear why but i think it
is clear that we can expect great things
from you
[Music]
you